well it's my great pleasure to introduce
dr. Mohamed ElBaradei the
director-general of the International
Atomic Energy Commission here to Yale
and we'll be talking about the state of
non-proliferation efforts around the
world today dr. Barrett is a pleasure to
be with you thank you very much for
having me Johnson well let me begin by
going back in history a little bit as
you know very well back in 1953
President Eisenhower proposed the Atoms
for Peace program and later something
like this was incorporated into the
nuclear non-proliferation treaty really
committing the nuclear powers to share
nuclear power technology including the
fuel cycle and lock stock and barrel to
to other countries around the world and
recently this of course has been a
problem do you think they made a mistake
back in 1953 in 1970 and should some
corrective action be taken I don't think
Jonathan they made a mistake I think the
basic assumption of atoms for peace
still quite valid that we need nuclear
technology to use for peaceful
application generating electricity using
nuclear techniques for curing disease
improving productivity of food managing
ground water etc there are lots of
beneficial you know uses of nuclear
energy but nuclear energy like any other
technology have as its dark side and the
whole atom for peace was based on this
assumption that let us maximize the
benefit of nuclear energy let us
minimise the risk and and that
assumption still valid today the
difference of course that technology has
evolved you know we we now know how that
the more application we can use nuclear
energy for but we also know how you can
really miss use a nuclear energy in many
different ways that were not known to us
before so what is needed is an
absolutely me adjusting the concept to
the current
the current a reality but where would
you draw the line in other words the
nuclear powers are permitted to have
everything nuclear weapons nuclear power
fuel cycle the whole shooting match so
to speak but the non-nuclear weapon
powers were also permitted at present to
have the fuel cycle but this seems to be
something of a Trojan horse within the
non-proliferation treaty so I'm
wondering if the adjustment would come
in this area and what it perhaps should
be I think you're right that the
non-proliferation treaty in 1970 you
know try to make the appropriate
adjustment at the type you know by
basically saying you know let us build
on the atoms for peace you know that
apiece for peace was not very specific
on the commitment not to have nuclear
weapons although it was meant that to
discourage development of nuclear
weapons but there was not the necessary
mechanist the NPT decided then to have a
clear-cut legal commitment everybody who
did not have nuclear weapons by nineteen
seventy or sickness 67 in fact well you
know should should not make a commitment
not to have nuclear weapon and the five
recognized nuclear weapon states at that
type made a commitment to move to a
nuclear disarmament so the basic legal
commitment the proper legal commitment
were made in 1970 what happened of
course is a number of events which led
us to where we are today the first of
course that there is a assists a sense
of collective insecurity that that is
even more you know then I think what we
had during the Cold War the Cold War
there was two blocks you know but there
was a clear delimitation light you know
and the concept of nuclear deterrence
was was clearly defined each one of the
two blocks have their own States to
protect that system has disappeared and
we talked about a that we were euphoric
at that time about a new world order
unfortunately we did not develop the new
order so we have this vacuum and where
when you still have like
30 countries relying on nuclear umbrella
under the NATO and different bilateral
arrangements the rest of the countries
in the world feel that they are left in
the cold you know that they don't have
this ultimate deterrent by the way does
anybody else other than 80 hold out a
nuclear umbrella I was just trying to
think it's you ready I think Japan which
is not member of NATO hasn't you know of
course but I mean is there any extender
of a nuclear umbrella other than the
United States I think it is Russia offer
it I'm not aware of that i think i think
the china i am not aware of that i think
it's primarily the nato umbrella you
know and and the u.s. bilateral was like
so so only the West has extended
differently this way deterrence as far
as I know so you have like around 30
countries to Australia to New Zealand
and you know some in addition to NATO
and and then you have the rest of the
world who feed wait a minute you know
these people have this ultimate
deterrence the nuclear umbrella and we
are left in the cold you know so this is
create in certain regions wait like the
Middle East like South Asia like the
Korean Peninsula a sense of insecurity
and of course add to that is a war of
words I mean we we have seen you know
the regime being described in different
you know names that we have seen present
state and so forth exactly and present
nejad you know talking about you know
Israel in a negative way of all this
rhetoric added to the sense of
insecurity in the world then the second
factor that we have now a technology
that is out of the tube you know that we
at the beginning or 20 30 years ago the
technology was limited to the highly
industrialized countries in they they
were regarded as the ones who can have
the technology to develop nuclear weapon
to develop enrichment technology
reprocessing technology to weaponize
well in the last ten years or so we have
seen that there has been an under
underground black market in nuclear
technology and we have realized that
countries with a average industrial
infrastructure
can develop nuclear weapons so that is
that's another important factor that we
could not just rely on export control
you know this export control maybe still
important but not crucial then then we
have again a new phenomenon which is as
you called it the Trojan horse that many
countries have come to realize that they
don't need to develop you know nuclear
weapon lock stock and barrel it's enough
to develop the capability you know to
enrich uranium ore to reprocess
plutonium because this is the key
component in developing nuclear weapons
and they know that if they have that
capability that's already enough
deterrence or should the NPT then seek
to stop you've used the good phrase
virtual nuclear weapon states to
describe those who have the near
capacity to make them but don't actually
go ahead and do it should one of the
goals of the NPT to be to prevent the
development of virtual weapons States as
well as nuclear weapon states I think so
I mean that the net effect is pretty
much the same I mean whether you have
nuclear weapon today or whether you can
have nuclear weapon in a matter of weeks
to me the net affected the same you will
have proliferation of either nuclear
weapon or nuclear nuclear keep weapon
capable way States and don't you isn't
there a problem though if you seek to
restrict the fuel cycle to prevent
certain countries from getting it while
others especially the nuclear powers
have it isn't there a problem of
deepening the double standard which
seems to undermine the whole ngot
Jonathan you cannot have it into those
who will keep that technology and those
who are told not to have the technology
we have seen the same haves and
have-nots under the NPT you know the
fact that the nuclear weapon states have
been sluggish on on their fulfilling
their commitment to to move to a nuclear
disarmament has resulted in many
countries saying what this haves and
have-nots is not sustainable let us try
to emulate you know that the weapon
estate the same is going to happen in
the end in the enrichment unless you
have an equitable system own everybody
agree that
enrichment or reprocessing is under
international multinational regional do
you think that the nuclear weapon states
would be prepared to surrender their own
national means to an international
authority that's an idea as you I'm sure
much aware that was first introduced by
the Atchison lilienthal plan way back in
nineteen forty six and when you have
been proposing this I've often thought
of that plan yeah absolutely i mean i
think they have to make a fundamental
choice you know either they are ready to
accept a principle of equity you know
that we that the interest community
today will not accept a system based on
let's have the cake and eat it or accept
or resign themselves to the fact that in
the next 10 20 years we'll have another
day 10 20 nuclear weapon capable States
and to me if we if we end up by not
having line nuclear weapon estate but
having 30 nuclear weapon estate well we
are fulfilling unfortunately you know
President Kennedy's prophecy and that
would be to me the beginning of the end
the more you have nuclear weapons States
the more that the probability that
nuclear weapons will be used either
intentionally or or or through error or
mistake you've been very forceful and
saying that the nuclear weapon powers
should fulfill their part of the NPT
bargain by stepping up to clear
disarmament I'm wondering whether you
think there could be any specific
mechanism that would link the
non-proliferation effort to the nuclear
disarmament effort of course in the NPT
article six makes that bargain and that
commitment is made but there's no
mechanism there's no forum there's no
negotiation there's no world body that
connects the two issues and creates the
quid pro quos and so forth but I I think
I think you're absolutely correct I mean
the NPT provides the framework then the
umbrella if you like but but we don't
have yet a detailed mechanism to link
progress on non-proliferation and
progress on this armored I mean
can have that clearly as part of the
non-proliferation review conference
which meets every five years to review
the implementation of the treaty by
agreeing on a road map for disarmament
you can have that through the conference
and disarm it in Geneva which has been
in you know almost on on a holiday for
the last 10 years since they have
completed the Chemical Weapons
Convention and the Comprehensive Test
Ban convention so that one can easily
find a mechanism the important thing is
are the weapon States ready to bite the
bullet agree that they really need to
take concrete steps toward nuclear
disarmament it I can't you know for the
life of me understand that why we still
left today was 27,000 warheads in
existence why we still do not have a
comprehensive test ban treaty in force
after 10 years you know of concluding
that treaty and then of course now you
know we are crying you know and the
international he is crying about North
Korea's testing but if testing is such
an important issue as it as it is you
know we should have made make clear that
this testing you know is legally bad why
do you think by the way at the end of
the code at the end of the Second World
War there was an effort actually to
abolish nuclear weapons that was the
baroque plan and the Soviets made their
own proposed of course it went nowhere
why do you think there was no comparable
effort you know successful or otherwise
at the end of the Cold War what why do
you think that there was so little done
in the nuclear disarmament area I know
there were reductions and so forth but
nothing is bold as the lilienthal at HSN
Lilienthal plan of the group plant where
correct I i need to give their dues to
the weapon estates we they move from I
think during the Cold War the highest of
Cold War we had 65 thousand words but we
moved to 27,000 button to me again this
is 27,000 too many why we have not moved
boldly into nuclear disarmament I think
a number of factors a inertia you know
we're used to nuclear deterrence it
worked so maybe we keep doing what we
have been doing although now all the
writing in the wall that it cannot it
cannot continue because the Terrance was
was already during the Cold War nuclear
deterrence might not work was in a
plethora of new nuclear weapon states
and i should add nuclear terrorism that
that phenomenon the idea that a
sophisticated group of terrorists will
acquire nuclear weapons the whole
concept of deterrence does not figure
because these people are will not
respond to any deterrence if they have
nuclear weapon they will use it I think
it's also frankly intellectual laziness
if I say then that we continue to talk
about nuclear disarmament but we haven't
really done much to develop an
alternative system of security that does
not depend on you can tell there seems
to be a paradox that the last two people
to very seriously talk about eliminating
nuclear weapons were Ronald Reagan and
Mikhail Gorbachev and the Reykjavik it
made me wonder whether the Cold War
wasn't a better context for these ideas
in the post-cold war period which would
be very paradoxical it is very
paradoxical that you know after the end
of the Cold War when we everybody think
that there is on that for for nuclear
weapon should not be there that we still
have the nuclear weapons of both Russia
and the US you know aimed at each other
on what Sam Nunn call it a hair-trigger
alert you know or the Cold War status
alert that each leader of these two
countries will only have half an hour to
decide whether to respond to a nuclear
attack a or e reported nuclear attack
this could be the result of a computer
error you know misinformation what have
you are we ready to you know risk that
you know absolute annihilation of at
least a good part of our civilization
because and at the end of the day we say
oops we made a mistake I mean it's it's
to me unconscionable I noticed that of
course Pakistan and India have acquired
nuclear weapons and recently the United
States has made a deal on nuclear power
with India and in that context the
Indian Prime Minister Singh said that
India was joining what he
called a new a new nuke a nuclear world
order a new nuclear world order and it
almost seemed that he had an idea of
organizing the world around the presence
of nuclear weapons rather than their
disappearance even though India over the
years has favored nuclear disarmament I
wonder if you could comment on that I
think the Indian change of attitude if
you like is a very good indication of
that change of attitude toward nuclear
disarmament you know India you're right
India narrow you know primary scenario
was one of the very first who called
about general and complete disarm and
euclid disarm and India you know for
years did not you know want to move into
being a nuclear weapon state they have
come to a point i think it point in time
when they have realized well we are 1
billion people you know we you know we
are having nuclear weapon states around
us you know and we don't see that the
nuclear weapon States moving to a
nuclear disarmament so until they do
that we we probably have to join them it
is regrettable that that happened but
that to my mind with the reading by
India and of course join later on by by
Pakistan of of the environment
environment as you rightly said Johnson
is based on nuclear weapon that a
nuclear weapon deterrence and does it
look that is going to change anytime
soon but it's the guardian of the NPT if
I may describe you that way aren't you
worried that this acceptance of the
Indian move towards the bomb by the
United States and maybe the
international community might tend to
weaken the NPT I don't think so frankly
because Indian never made the commitment
to join the NPT so they haven't really
violated any legal obligation neither
was Pakistan neither was Israel for that
matter I think the weapon is accepting
India you know as a nuclear weapon is
difficult for the weapon state to say we
will not accept you you know as as a
nuclear weapon while they continue
themselves to hold on to nuclear weapon
and and not only that but trying to
develop weapons that are usable you know
the other issue is that whether
accepting India or not it is a reality
you know and I have raised the question
a number of times if there were to be a
nuclear war between India and Pakistan
are we going to say this is not a
nuclear war because we don't recognize
them it is it is a reality and being you
know a as you said a custodian of the
regime but also being a pragmatist I
thought it is important that to bring
India on board and bring Pakistan on
board and bring Israel and board and
hopefully get all these countries who
hold nuclear weapon or nuclear weapon
capability to work together towards
nuclear disarmament India and Pakistan
are facts on the ground we cannot say we
don't see them as the best approach to
me is to say all right you know they are
there let us bring them closer to talk
to the regime and let us work with them
to move to a neutral disarm let me
change the subject a little bit of
course before the Iraq war your agency
and also Hans Blix were saying they
couldn't find much evidence of of a
nuclear program no evidence in Iraq but
let me ask you this were you at all
surprised when at the end of the war it
turned out that they're literally was no
such program in Iraq was there any
element of surprise in your reaction or
did it merely confirm what you would
believe previously you know we hear that
every intelligence agency in the world
believe that they did have the the
programs and so forth and yet your
agency and Hans Blix were saying
otherwise so I just wonder if there was
any element of surprise in your reaction
I don't think there was any surprise
Jonathan we have been in the in Iraq for
you know from 91 to 97 when we know that
we dismantle destroyed all Iraq nuclear
weapon capability then we went back in
2002 you know and we haven't seen any
indication of a revival of the nuclear
weapon program our people are the most
seasoned experienced inspectors who have
a lot of experience with with Iraq and
all the reports i was getting we don't
see any smoking gun anywhere and and
that's what i was reporting to the
Security Council in fact
you know I you know I i remember i think
in january of 2003 this couple of months
before the war I said I need three
months to to you know to complete my job
and I said these three months will be
investment in peace so I was not
surprised but I should say I was
unfortunately relieved that we were
right but but that relief was coupled
with a lot of grief that we we ended up
losing a lot of innocent lives in in
that war as that was launched on the
basis of a false assumption and that
that Iraq is developing weapon of mass
destruction let me ask I mean you're
really somebody who's in the engine room
of the non-proliferation efforts so to
speak and of course you act by peaceful
means by diplomacy inspection through
the treaty the non-proliferation treaty
do you think that there's any role we've
just been speaking of the Iraq war for
military action in a non-proliferation
effort and of course difficult to say to
give a sweeping response no but in
general in general I would say I don't
find a use of force at all to be a
solution to any of the non-proliferation
issues these are very complex issues
that has to do with a sense of isolation
a sense of insecurity a sense of a
feeling that that that the regime
survival is at stake and if I take Iran
for example which is a which is a
current issue I see absolutely no
military solution it would be completely
counterproductive I don't see a military
solution for North Korea it would be
completely counterproductive I still
believe you know we need to go blend you
say counterproductive what do you mean
well what I mean that if you use force
for example in either if I use force in
Iraq you know there are no military
nuclear facilities to be bombed and I
know if you use
force at all it would be a rallying
point for all the Iranians you know to
go for an accelerated program for a
nuclear weapon we have not come to a
firm conclusion that this is a weapon
program we still saying the jury is out
so it will be counterproductive in fact
that even if they are not working for a
nuclear weapon program any use of force
will completely you know put the hard
liner in the driver force put the
national pride you know into the front
seat and and and lead to an acceleration
of a weapon program we have seen some of
that in a way you know in North Korea
the more you try to isolate the country
you know the more you try to put
pressure you know alone without using
engagement the more a country will will
feel tempted to develop nuclear weapons
so I I don't really see that I see I
still believe maybe I am very
traditionalist but I still believe that
diplomacy engagement understanding where
people are coming from providing them a
sense of security that's a basic thing
you need to engage but you need need
also to assure them that either the
regime is not at you know is not
threatened that that you are not going
to use you know new force against them
and and that they're secure there is a
mechanism for security I've just said at
the beginning Johnson that they still
with all our rhetoric they still 30
countries sitting comfortably under a
nuclear umbrella and other people feel
you know that they are bit sitting in
the in the fresh air you know and we
need we need to you know find a solution
to this dilemma you know that we need a
system of security that is comprehensive
inclusive equitable other than that we
will continue to see this periodic
temptation for country to develop
nuclear web just in closing this is a
another strong theme of yours the need
for an alternative or a new security
system to reassure countries though they
don't try to get nuclear weapons could
you just say a few words about what some
of the elements of such a system might
be in closing well I think some of the
element of that that we we need to
provide some
of security to all countries you know we
need to have a strong security council
that can provide this system of
collective security protect countries
against attack against aggression that
it also maybe use the Security Council
as a custodian of a very very small
arsenal of nuclear weapons to be used
jointly you know in case of a possible
cheat you know so we we obviously
worried about a possible cheat if we go
to zero in nuclear disarmament so but
but we can probably use the Security
Council both for conflict prevention and
to deter aggression and ultimately to be
able to deal with with a possible cheat
JV maybe the Security Council should
become one of these virtual weapon
possessors it could it could be at least
for a while but ultimately I think we
need to send the message to the people
that we you know let us focus on our
understanding that we are one human
family you know that that really we are
not our fight should not be about
borders about ethnicity about religion
because we have reached through
globalization a stage of human
development that we know that either we
are going to survive together and
prosper together or we are going to sink
together and that I think we need to
continue to speak up up on these issues
but I I would urge and i'm here at yale
that there's a lot were cut for for
academia there's a lot of work art for
political scientists nuclear physicist
let's not just talk about we don't like
what we see nuclear you know arms
reliance on nuclear weapon we really
need to work on an alternative system of
security engineering that the Security
Council developing a different security
posture there's a lot of work that we
need to do and it might take time it is
difficult it is complex but I think that
time to start is now because what we
have today is an absolutely unacceptable
situation well thank you very much it's
been a great pleasure to talk it has
been great pleasure to be with your
domicile thank you very much